how're you doing today sir really good
yeah I want to thank you so much for
coming in but before we do the interview
the only reason I get to do these
interviews because of the house for aura
they're our sponsor partner and I want
to give them a huge thank you before the
interview starts thank you House of
Aurora for being a great partner so
you've worked with Steve on all of his
movies if I'm not mistaken yeah I've got
total full feature films what was it
like the first time you met him did you
have any idea that he was going to be
such a great director Steve was really
well known for having won the Turner
Prize in London so I knew of him and I'd
seen one of his art pieces but it was
really hard to get you know normally
when you meet somebody for an interview
you kind of get all their movies out and
sort of try and kind of do your prep but
in this case I couldn't get my hands on
anything
I think his near show was in Berlin so I
just went by you know meeting him and we
discovered that we actually grew up in
the same part of London Ealing in a
small you know suburb of London so we
had a lot in common straightaway you
know how I know he really likes you
because he's worked with you for I think
four times yeah because if you didn't
like you you would have been cut after
the first one or the second one yeah you
know what I mean that's one of those did
you ever have you ever thought about
that like oh you must really actually
like me or like my work we just it's 10
or 11 years I think we've been together
now and it's it's very unusual you know
I've done four films to Steve and three
films with Danny via nerve and it's like
I'm used to these people being there's
some four feet away from me most of the
time so I'm like family what would
surprise people to learn about all of
his movies do they generally run long
and you have like crazy long first cuts
or is he pretty brutish in terms of on
the shoot they're very economical in the
way that they film
I mean Sean and Steve have been working
together far longer than the two of us
have worked together and they you know
they shoot they try to kind of achieve
things in one s and in one take as much
as they possibly can in one shot and
there's a lot of that in the films it's
kind of sometimes a bit of a challenge
isn't edited to try and kind of make
that work but you know it's a signature
style
he hates the word coverage
which other directors do all the time is
many different angles of the same thing
Steve's have allergic to that so he
tends to limit the number of choices and
they also shoot on film single camera so
it's really great for me I don't have to
wade through hours now some material
every day I mean it doesn't Roger
Deakins do the same thing it's true yeah
even on Sicario I think there was only
one sequence that had more than one
camera yeah its III I think well he's
reached to the point in his career where
no one's gonna say [ __ ] to him so you
know it's like if I want to do it that
way it's gonna be done that way it's a
bit of a joy you know that's the thing
isn't it with these kind of choices of
photography you look at their material
and looking at their dailies every day
and you feel like okay I'm the guy who
gets to cut this today which is unique
I'm the only person cutting their stuff
today and no it's a real blessing how
much are you involved with the do Peas
in the footage in the editing room how
much is it like you looking at
everything and doing your pass and maybe
they come in later
what's that relationship well you know
there's that there's kind of politics to
that you know I did I try to keep out
that way I mean it's a very intimate
relationship on set with the director of
photography and their director and I
don't only come in in the middle of that
I don't to get in the way I mean we also
have sufficient respect for each other I
kind of know what they're doing what
they're trying to achieve and they know
what I'm trying to achieve and you know
hopefully we'd like what each other's
doing I it's I tend to keep a deliberate
distance but what about in the editing
room though yeah is still still I mean
Sean of course has seen the cut and is
very involved with the grading of course
of the film but he's you know we've been
on the cut for a long time and Sean's
made another film or maybe even two
sometimes so it's great to have them
back in with a kind of fresh take on
their material that they shot maybe you
know ten months before jumping into
widows I don't want to do any spoilers
but I will say that the beginning of the
movie has some very interesting and cool
editing cool was that always in the
script was that something you discovered
in the edit we it was you know the whole
film it's our ha it's a heist movie
fundamentally it's a heist shanwa film
and the kind of typical editing pattern
of those is you know accelerating pace
too
thrilling conclusion and of course you
know it's me and Steve so we kind of
tried to subvert that sometimes but we
do start with the kind of really
confrontational I'd say opening and
cross cutting a morning and an evening
and a heist gone wrong and it's very
very hopefully very arresting and gives
you a jolt of energy but it definitely
does and lays out the stall of these
four widows
so and then you know it's it's all very
finely tuned stuff you know we we'd
worked on everything really hard
actually a real joy the other night was
hearing a big laugh for one particular
line and it was always a joke that I
think only me and Steve ever found funny
for like two or three screenings we had
where you just get a little chuckle and
then last night we've got a big like
laughs and that was we'd gone back in
there and we did a really tasteless cut
to make it work and it's kind of a bit
of a joy to see it working everything
like that's very finely tuned talked a
little bit about with the four films
he's made have any dramatically shifted
in the Edit compared to what maybe you
thought it was gonna be going in all of
them I mean all of them but twelve years
of slavery is a really big version of
that I mean originally the story was
based on Solomon's diary which you know
is a linear story he starts as a free
man and then he's abducted into slavery
and then we assembled the film that way
and it was some weeks into doing a
director's cut fit where we thought this
isn't really a merciful off and we found
a way of putting all you know immersing
the audience in the slave experience at
the beginning of the film and then
showing all of that early material as a
flashback and you know my career is
largely based on a very simple trick
which is if you have a shot of somebody
looking very thoughtful and then you cut
to something it looks like they're
thinking about it so and hence arrival
and 12 years of slave there was a lot of
really good material I could just weave
into the slave story so talked a little
bit about with widows how long was the
first cut compared to the finished film
I'm not too sure it was it was a little
over and we had to kind of cut
a fair amount of material there's a huge
cast I mean it's a big ensemble really
so it's like having a table with you
know spinning plates and you know part
of the joy though I think in the cut
that we've made is seeing how things
assemble and kind of link together and
sometimes one of the joys of it is
you're following a thread and then you
go completely left field and introduce a
new character and you haven't really
worked out quite how they connect and
seeing that track in into a kind of big
finale is fantastic did you do any
screenings and did what did you learn
from those screenings that impacted the
finished film they're really important
to us
screenings with family and friends of
course we asked people to be brutal and
honest and it's not you know they do
test screenings where you get 350 people
who are invited to see a film and that's
kind of always instructive but I
wouldn't say necessarily reading the
paperwork is the most instructive thing
for me the most important thing is how
does it feel in the room how does it
play and have you got them gripped are
there lots of people going for a toilet
break halfway through it are people
reloading popcorn halfway through you
know when did you lose them and it's a
very useful thing for an editor because
we all willing on some sequences that
may not work and we have to kind of go
through that experience to be able to
kind of take out a few strands and see
if it works better
so what lot which were there any
storylines that got removed in Widow's
I'm sure there were I mean there was a
lot of structural changes the way that
you know violas character Veronica
remembers her past is in a very
different order for example of how it
was planned and it felt like there was a
right time in the script to kind of deep
dive into her character which was I
think later than it was intended that
kind of thing I want to jump backwards I
you cut black hat if I'm not mistaken
yes and so there is a extended cut of
that film that's now on like FX were you
involved in that extended cut no but I'm
curious about that I wonder if it's the
cut I left I was on the project for a
year and at the point I left it there
was a very robust cart and and I wonder
whether he maybe I don't know too much
about it I'm only speculating that he
might
back to that cart because there was it
came out and then he it came out and
then they did this extended cut now I
haven't seen the extended cut yet and
I'm just wondering how much footage was
removed from that the actual cut that
maybe could have gone in because I guess
it's a lot longer I think the big change
was an order change but I'm speculating
I haven't seen this what he's put up and
Michael's very you know revise his cuts
and it's constantly working on that
material he's constantly plowing the
field so I haven't tracked that latest
change um I still want to go in depth on
that one but let's jump into what I call
Blade Runner 2049 which is a movie I
absolutely love Danny said that his
original cut was a lot longer than what
actually ended up getting released so
what was it like being a part of that
film well a great experience the third
film with Denny and we'd went did three
films back to back more or less I mean
there was a short gap between Sicario
and arrival and there was no gap I mean
I finished the last shot on arrival
which was putting in a shot of Amy Adams
hair in zero gravity on a Friday and I
was in Budapest on a Monday so it was a
straight run where you know Denny's
basically effectively three feet away
from me for two years it was you know
let's get out of body it's really weird
not having him three feet away from me
that's kind of oddest thing but no we
really I loved working on that project
I've seen much more ambitious you know
VFX in CGI there were eleven hundred
shots and that's a different way of
editing you know you have to wait
patiently for things to come on board
well I'm curious because again he had a
Mike told me a much longer cut what were
you sad to see go you know it's not
quite true what what what he's saying
though there's you know there's like
week I got into this discussion because
I think most people don't realize that a
first assembly is often a lot longer oh
you know especially when there are kind
of experimental things like for example
there was a baseline test in that film
if you remember where he's reciting Pale
Fire and there was in Mike as first
assembly I put a lot of that in because
it was really really good and we all
knew that we'd only use a pepper
with a tiny little faction of it but you
know you probably could have come out
and you know brewed a cup of tea while
that was playing so it was a long first
assembly and we actually broke it into
two because our bladders are not that
robust these days well I think maybe he
did say that to me that there was talk
at the studio I'm doing two parts it
it's funny when we did break it into
almost accidentally we broke it at the
point where he's had sex with Mariette
and and it's the beginning of part two
was her waking up in bed and it was just
struck us that it drew attention to the
fact that that's unusually a film in two
halves that it starts with an eye
opening and the second half starts with
an eye opening and there's a very
different Kay in the first half where
he's come to terms with his past and
being a real boy in the second half and
that was just the way that we viewed it
I'm not sure it was considered to be a
to film release no no I think this I
could be mistaken it's been a while but
I believe he said to me that the studio
asked if he wanted to do with two-parter
yeah it's very hard to throw away stuff
like that I mean look his his in
practice when you're editing something
like that if you're really a sequence
where woman arrives at office to see her
boss you can imagine a setup shot her an
establishing shot of her climbing the
stairs into that office you probably
only need three to five seconds to tell
that story in a in a conventional film
on Blade Runner I've got a world-class
shot of this amazing caustic light
effect following Sylvia Hertz who's
amazing to look at climbing up the steps
and the first person that you see in the
office is a man in the shadows a blind
man in the shadows with artificial
sunlight crawling and raking across a
huge water set so I'm gonna need to make
that three point three to five seconds
long is is killing a major world-class
shot well the other thing is of course
there's people like me who just loved
the world of Blade Runner and those
longer shots just allow us to live in
that world even longer
I think there's I mean for me the cinema
experience is
at its best when you get to really peer
inside the soul of somebody and really
track what's going on in the mind and
and especially with the character like
Kay who's a little shut down and stoic
and and uncommunicative sometimes I
found it fascinating to look into his
eyes and you know I don't to get in the
way of that as an editor I want to give
you space to enjoy that moment you know
sure what so I maybe I asked this
already but what which was the scene
that you wish because it again like with
a two-part version I know there must be
some deleted scenes which is the one
that maybe you were sad to see go it's
been too long I've got I've got no
memory for pain I'm sure you know it's
like childbirth probably you know but
you don't remember the pain which is why
you volunteered to do it I said I will I
will jump off that and go to a rival
yeah which I loved
talk a little bit about being a part of
that film and maybe how that film got
changed in the editing room arrival was
you know the most compelling thing was
always this stunning you know Amy Adams
performance and we always knew that that
was kind of working beautifully and what
we needed to help with you know a script
is one thing and that was a brilliant
script it's a page-turner but you know
in a script you can point out what's
going on in a verbal way that sometimes
doesn't translate to screen and we we
had to kind of reposition the moment
where everybody realizes what really is
going on and and kind of make a stronger
impact because otherwise people are left
to still be puzzling it out at the end
of the film we didn't want that we want
people to really know what the choice
was at the end which I think it's very
emotional oh it's very emotional and
also our I think Denny saved our asses a
little bit by shooting a lot of green
screens and monitors without any
particular purpose of where they're
going to be Anna meant that that gave us
an opportunity in the Edit to build up
the outside world and we could do create
little you know news stories that were
going on to give you an idea of why the
tensions are building up outside the
compound yeah I I don't want to say
because there's gonna be people watching
this that have not seen it right yeah
and I don't want to do spoilers but if
I've seen it a few times and every
single time I watch it there's a scene
in the third act building towards
something and it gets me every single
time you know it's uh it's just so well
put together you know talk a little bit
about like for example without spoiling
it but putting together that stuff with
Denis and and because you're pulling you
know it's like some of the stuff was
beauty you know there's I've learned
something with Denny that I I think I
stubbornly refused to learn before and
that was that if you know sometimes a
crazy idea you just go with it you know
there's no point talking somebody out of
trying something it's much better to
have a go and do it and sometimes you're
going well that's illogical it's never
gonna work I'm never gonna be able to
cut a little and it's so much better to
just knock something together in and see
what happens because there was one scene
for example in the middle of that which
is a nightmare sequence in the film
where you see a kind of discussion in in
a kind of Winnebago or a kind of army
barracks and you know there's a very
crew jump cut but it started life is a
completely different scene and we
twisted it around to make it somebody's
dream and we ended up with a giant hepta
pod floating in there kind of back of
the room but it didn't start out as said
it was us saying we need this part of
the story to identify what's going on in
the film this idea of the sapir-whorf
theory if you know the film that's kind
of more apparent but they the idea was
if we didn't say it we're never gonna
say it in the film and where did we say
it and then we just Denny just said well
why don't we just cut the bits we need
together and in doing so there was a
kind of gloriously clunky cut between
two shots of jeremy renner mismatching
which didn't look smooth or nice at all
but it kind of signified that there was
something wrong and then you hold on Amy
for awfully long time looking off-screen
you think you're gonna cut to Colonel
Weber forest forest part and instead you
reveal a giant hepta pod floating and
then it's a dream but that you know I
wouldn't we would never found that kind
of accident if I hadn't tried it and
also is such a valuable thing in the
story to be inside her mind and not such
a bad thing for her to be dreaming of
Jeremy Renner's character as well
because you have
some forward traction from that
completely when did you realize because
again I want to reiterate how much I
love the movie thank you when when did
you realize this was gonna be such a
special movie I you know honestly when I
read the script on you it's gonna be
good I really knew it was going to be
good but I mean when I start the first
week of shooting they I was getting all
this amazing footage you know
Bradford's shooting stuff on the
lakeside with the child if you remember
that it's glorious with this delicious
kind of Sherpa T colors and and this
exquisite performance from ami and this
child and I thought that's on day one or
two or three or something you're going
this is going to be special yeah
Bradford cinematography is also
phenomenal amazing yeah absolutely
jumping into Sicario know what do you
remember from that experience Sakura we
said joyful that was my first time in in
this [ __ ] country I was in Montreal and
we came up to work there and I've been I
was a Londoner and I moved to LA at
around the time 12 years a slave and
then moved up to Montreal so that was
really nice it was kind of being under
the radar a little bit we could go and
make our mistakes in the cutting room
far away from prying eyes and Sicario
was very well they're great planners
Denny and Roger and the amazing
storyboard artist Sam Hideki they kind
of think things through with the
production designer and that was very
well planned but the the the the thing
that I tried to crack on that edit the
thing that changed the most was trying
to maximize emily Blunt's kind of
character's point of view you know she's
a moral woman watching immoral activity
and she's kind of asks as we're watching
and trying to piece things together so
it led to for example we dropped an
absolutely awesome opening scene with
Benicio del Toro which had to hit the
cutting room floor that is basically a
scene in which he's in Terry he's
drowning a man he goes too far and kills
him before he's got the answer he once
so he drags him on to the shore and then
resuscitates him only to start
interrogating him again and that was
hard to cut that was really hard to cut
but you know by by discovering
it's character through Emily at the time
when she first meets him it just
benefited the film it anchored it in her
viewpoint did you ever think that it was
gonna be there would be a sequel I
didn't know I mean I haven't you
honestly I haven't had time to see the
secret I'm dying to see I want to see it
on a big screen while it's still there
it is it feels a little weird because it
feels like you know looking at your
ex-partners baby
or something I will tell you I really
enjoyed the sequel but Sicario is still
you know then the music you know Rogers
work oh yeah and your Hansons it's
amazing it's it's next level you know it
adds so much it's a combination it's the
alchemy of everyone's you know you know
contribution everyone is firing on high
cylinders they're not you know I
remember as well the the opportunity on
that film was something that really
worked on as a script and really worked
on set and it was the glorious kind of
rare occasion where you're working on an
edit we are not having to change
anything too much because the story
works
you're just fine-tuning the detail so
all the kind of every little frame of
the bridge sequence for example is meant
to be you know frame accurate perfect
timing
where do you put a shot of a dog barking
where's the perfect time in that
sequence to ratchet up the tension you
know no it was fun it was a luxury job
my last thing for you
I believe that Denis will be doing dune
and he's talked about it as a two-parter
how much are you familiar with dune do
you know I kept away from June
discussions I'm seeing to any straight
after this interviewed her for a cup of
tea I have and I'll find out more but
you know I want to be fresh I you know
it's good for me to come in from outside
a little bit and read the script when
they're ready with it if if it's coming
my way and that's not a certainty but I
just you know I kind of don't want to
load it too much with the older film or
reading the book I just want to see what
his vision is completely I have a
million other things but there's about
to be a huge party and we need to in
party I think that you could okay I need
so I'm just gonna say thank you so much
for coming in and it was a really big
fan of your work
and I really recommend widows thank you
so much that's really good to talk to
you thank you
you